good morning everybody
we are back to the press room with um
commissioner janaz nanati who is of
course in charge of um crisis management
now the community commissioner will make
a short statement um
about the boosting of the strategic
medical
stockpile and the rescue following which
will also take
a few questions commissioner please take
the call
thank you good morning
as you are aware the coveted pandemic
has exposed some serious vulnerabilities
in how the international community
responds
to global emergency like a pandemic
and one of the most striking issues at
the start
of this health crisis related
to the limited availability of personal
protective equipment and also other
vital medical supplies worldwide
this situation this concern
was shared by many countries including
our
member states if you recall the state of
play
at the end of march at the end of
february
most member states had limited
stockpiles
and struggled to provide the necessary
supplies
for their own needs as well as for
others who
asked for assistance
in response to that situation the
commission
quickly undertook a series of steps to
ensure
that no member states would ever fall
behind
in the same manner again we took action
primarily on two tracks that continue
first in march we established a new
rescue life-saving medical equipment
reserve
through this reserve by now more than
half a million
units of ffp2 and ffp3
protective face max masks have already
been delivered
to italy spain croatia
lithuania as well as north macedonia
montenegro and serbia
these are professional masks intended
for first responders
like medical staff civil protection
teams
police and the like with winter
approaching
and coronavirus is increasing
throughout europe it is crucial that we
continue
to build up our stocks in this view
i am happy to inform that denmark
greece hungary and sweden
have joined germany and romania
as host states of the rescue
medical stocks with 100 percent
financial support from the european
commission
six eu member states are now in the
process
of building a common european stockpile
of life-saving equipment and other vital
medical supplies
these reserves are to be distributed
throughout the european union at times
of
medical emergencies when national health
systems would be
simply overwhelmed
the second trek started in june
when the european commission put forward
a targeted proposal
to strengthen the european union's
crisis management system
including the european union's civil
protection mechanism
the objective of this proposal is to
provide the european commission
with more tools to support european
union member states
as they seek to prepare and respond
to complex disasters this proposal
will also help strengthen the european
response coordination center
this proposal aims at the following
first better preparedness
by creating a rescue strategic reserve
at eu level plus the possibility
for the commission to directly procure
capacities second
faster response as to once a disaster
strikes we should be ready to respond
immediately by disposing a logistical
capacity
to ensure timely transport and delivery
of assistance
and third improved risk management
and planning for high impact emergencies
through the development of eu resilience
goals
i would like to clarify here that it is
important to note
that these strategic capacities will be
supplementary
to those of the eu member states
the fact remains that civil protection
is the national capacity of member
states
and the european union is to play a
supportive role
we would like to pre-position
strategically
this capacity in such a way
as to ensure the most effective
geographic coverage
in response to an emergency
to conclude with the
increased number of host states rescue
is stepping up our preparedness
with these new measures as well we will
be much stronger
in fighting this current pandemic as
well as better prepared for possible
other crisis in future
in view of the july european council
agreement
that has topped up the total budget for
the civil protection to 3 billion
i also count on the councils and
parliament's
continued support in this endeavor
with that i'm happy to take a few cash
questions
this is the time for us to take a few
questions i see many hands up which
shows the
important interest in this topic i will
start with
maria sarah
good morning can you hear me
now yes it's perfect okay thank you
thank you commissioner thank you vice
president
first of all i i have two questions if i
may the first one is
um greece is from uh today uh
participating
but what does that mean in practical
terms
if you could deliberately more what all
these countries
and how will act
now that they're they're part of this
initiative and the second question if i
make about lesbos
if you could um inform us about the
state of play of the help
of the member states to lesbos it would
be
very useful thank you very much
thank you the rescue in practical terms
works like this
we need member states who procure
and store on behalf of european union
the medical capacity the reserve
strategic capacity
for a situation of a crisis this
system does not replace the national
responsibility
civil protection as i said already is
national competence that means that
every member state
is responsible to have sufficient stock
of the necessary
capacity of the necessary items and
materials in order to face
possible crisis situations but we know
that
some crises are of bigger magnitude than
others and it often happens that
national
capacities are overwhelmed for that
situation we have the union civil
protection mechanism
through which a member state can ask for
assistance
and then other member states may respond
and offer the items requested then we
have the third level
when there is a extraordinary crisis
like this pandemic
whenever when everybody is facing
similar challenges
and in such situations we also have the
european level reserve the so-called
rescue
but for that we need member states
who procure and store
these reserves for that for that purpose
so in practical terms we sign a grant
agreement
with member states now we have six of
them
with whom we have signed such an
agreement and we
coordinate with them what items and what
quantities they buy
and store for the european rescue
strategic
reserve what matters here is that
at the moment of need at the moment of
severe crisis
it is the commission that decides where
such capacities need to be deployed and
when
and the commission will decide that on
the basis of objective criteria
in order to make sure that such capacity
is available to member states that needs
them most on your second question
the situation in lesbos following the
maurya fires
is extremely worrying
people were left without shelter without
food water sanitation facilities and so
on
following a request from greek
authorities
through the civil protection mechanism
we have immediately activated this
mechanism
and in the following few days following
this request
more than 100 000 items
tents blankets and the like shelter
water sanitation
items were delivered to greece in order
to help
alleviate this situation this is a proof
of the added value of the european union
civil protection mechanism
and of the solidarity of member states
with greece
and of course with the inhabitants
of the uh destroyed moriya camp thank
you
thank you commissioner i will continue
with david karate
i think there's an issue with the
microphone
try to press speak
waiting a bit for you to activate your
microphone
okay if not while david is trying to set
up the
i.t issues i'm going to continue with
thomas
spector
masks now in stock um clearly the
netherlands
thomas we missed the beginning of the
question if you could restart okay
yeah i restart um as i understood it
there is about one million
ffp2 masks now in stock only the
netherlands needed in
april and march and april uh four
million
ffp2 mosques a week so
how useful this is to have one million
now in stock for the whole of europe
which she
needs even much more than these uh
formerly
isn't this a symbolic gesture
this is more than just symbolic gesture
it's also a practical gesture
at the moment it's true there is about
one million ffp
2 and ffp 3 masks in the stock but this
stock will grow
this stock will grow both in romania and
germany which were first
to to offer their cooperation
in the buildup of the rescue but that we
now have
as i said four additional member states
so this figure will
increase however
these masks in accordance with the
philosophy of the civil protection
are not intended for general population
these are professional masks
of high quality which are intended for
primarily for the first responders as i
mentioned
these are medical personnel their civil
protection
teams and police and similar first
responders
you will recall that in late february
early march
this was one of the key vulnerabilities
in some of the member states where the
medical personnel was required
to work without proper protection
that's what we would like to avoid in
the future and that is the focus
of rescue when it comes to personal
protective equipment
maybe last question since the mid day
briefing is about to to start
i will give the floor to philip
blankenshop
press speak please so we can hear you
we are almost there we had a glimpse of
you phillip
oh okay
you mentioned that in terms of p2 and
fp3 masks
uh there was something like a million in
store at the moment
can you say what the the plan is sort of
going into winter how many you will have
maybe you can just outline a little bit
the conditions under which
member states who are in urgent need of
these masks
what conditions would they have to feel
fulfilled presumably also would they
have to pay for them
themselves or would they get them for
free
thank you the assistance that is
provided
through the union civil protection
mechanism including
that sku is free it is not
for purchasing so these masks would be
distributed for free
how when and to whom such decisions
will be based on the objective criteria
that will take into account the data
reliable data on the situation in the
country
concerned that means the civility of the
crisis
but also the obligation of every member
state to have
reasonable stocks of her own
because i repeat the rescue concept
does not absolve member state of their
own responsibility for having reasonable
stock in place in order to face such an
emergency as for instance
we are facing at the moment the surge in
the cases
of covet 19 in most
of europe so the fact is that
evidently the member states are now
better prepared
but we can still not disregard a
possibility
that one or more of them would be
overwhelmed in the coming months
especially due to the combination of the
risk between covet
and the seasonal flu so we need to be
prepared
we are preparing ourselves this initial
stock
will continue to grow as i said we just
signed a
grant agreement with four additional
member states so we'll have
we'll have sizable rescue reserve in
place
that will be available for extraordinary
circumstances
commissioner if you allow i see one more
hand up so i will invite nikola grow to
ask his question
[Music]
[Music]
so much
okay it is precisely the experience
of late february and early march
that led us to do what
we have been doing on expanding the
rescue reserve
previously the european commission did
not have
at its disposal a rescue reserve
of medical equipment including personal
protective equipment
because that was never considered by
member states to be necessary although
ideas were floated to this effect
already years ago
we entered
the pandemic under the general
impression that
everybody will manage we receive signals
that from the member says that they are
prepared
until end of february one member state
ran out of personal protective equipment
and even more worrying when that member
state requested assistance
no other member state responded
the european union civil protection
mechanism did its part
it activated the civil protection
mechanism
conveyed the italian request to all
other member states at
and call for assistance it was not for
coming
because there was general shortage of
equipment following which
the commission immediately proposed
an implementing act to expand the rescue
reserve
which until then only consisted of
firefighting planes because that was the
agreement
that we had from the member states
so we quickly in two weeks
received an agreement from member states
to expand
to expand this rescue so is also to
include medical equipment
and personal protective equipment on
19th of march
this implementing act was published in
the official journal of the eu and
became legal illegally in force
but that was a time when you recall of
general shortage of equipment not only
in europe but world fight
there was a worldwide competition
competition
for limited supplies of the equipment
nevertheless millions of masks
were sent to italy we received as the
commission
donations from a couple of sources and
those donations
we dispatched to countries that were
most affected
first and foremost italy but also spain
and thereafter some others
in other words it took time for the
commission
to be able to form such a reserve
such reserve is now in place and it is
growing precisely in order to avoid
a situation that we had at the end of
february
this has to be avoided this is the
lesson that we learned this is the
lesson that everybody has to learn
but the fundamentals remain the same
national competence includes
responsibility for civil protection and
preparedness
for crisis member states are responsible
for that
the commission plays a supportive role
since we could not support
sufficiently the member states we asked
to
increase our tool our tools to increase
our ability
to support them and this is now taking
place
so is to avoid the situation that we
faced at the end of february
and early march thank you commissioner
for updating us on the state of play of
the medical
stockpile and thank you for our viewers
for tuning in and raising your questions
and now we'll continue
with the midday briefing thank you
[Music]
you